are you too young to start a business
it's a question that came in from Manon
who's one of my YouTube viewers I hope I
pronounced that properly and the answer
is no with with power it's known you're
never too young to start a company you
can get started right now the only thing
that's gonna hold you back is do you
believe that you're too young because if
you believe that you are too young to
start a business then it doesn't matter
what tips practical advice I give you
nothing's gonna work out because you
don't believe that you're gonna make it
so that's what you got a change you have
to change your mindset to start so man
you wrote on to say you know I'm 18
years old I wanted to start it in the
fashion business and here's what's more
troubling there are so many other
clothes stores that will sell the same
kind of products as I would like to sell
does that make it a bad idea the problem
here is not your age the problem here is
what you're selling if everybody else is
selling the same thing then you're not
gonna have success you have to be
different if you're making your own
stuff or if you're importing some other
people's stuffer or repin somebody else
it's got to be different if you look at
the most successful entrepreneurs in the
world all of them are different you may
not agree with what they do but they
stand for something and their products
and their services means something
that's what you need to do with your
company if everybody else is already
selling the same stuff you are not going
to have success move to something else
that's the the easiest way to get
started
and the mistake that most entrepreneurs
make so this is a challenge that you
have to overcome it's easy to say hey I
want to start a fashion business and go
find you know tons of different clothes
that everybody else is selling put them
in a store or an online store that's not
gonna sell the harder work is really
identifying what it is that you stand
for what do you believe in what's the
impact that you want to make and it
comes from here comes from you as a
person what you personally want to do
and that gets reflected in everything
that you do in your clothing and how you
set up your shop everything in your
personal life but it it's all related
what is it that you stand for what is
the mark
you want to leave start there and then
start to apply it to the products that
you make or you sell do these products
match up with what you believe in or not
so you're not just selling clothes
anymore you're part of a movement you've
created something that people can attach
to now you become a lot more powerful
believe that you can do it and it has
nothing to do with your age you say
you're 18 I had my first real business
when I was 19 and I was selling to
companies and I was selling to people
who were three times my age who had PhDs
and I was afraid at the start I had a
great product I had a great team but I
didn't make sales at the beginning
because I didn't believe that I was able
to do it I believed I had a great
product but but my limiting belief was
that I was too young and once I got over
that once I realized hey this is
something I can really help these guys
then they didn't care and they bought
once I let go of that belief I was able
to make sales and applies for any
limiting personal belief it's not just
are you too young it could be are you
too old you believe you're too old
you're not going to be successful if you
have a belief that because you're a
woman you're not gonna be successful if
you believe that because you're an
immigrant you're not gonna be successful
because you have an accent you're not
gonna be successful none of that matters
it's only in your head
if you believe that you can have success
and you can have success and you'll find
a way to do it believe for those of you
watching you liked the video please give
it a thumbs up below makes me to do more
for you and I want to know what you have
to think do you like this video leave a
comment for those of you who are
stalkers we just watch all the videos
but don't say anything this is your
chance leave a comment below please I
wanna know what you have to think and if
you have a question leave it below -
I'll make you a video response for you
thank you guys let's see you soon
you